- [Interviewer] Okay, Floyd.
So, tell me where you're from.
- My name is Floyd.
I'm from Texas.
- [Interviewer] And you've been out -
You came to Skid Row when?
- [Floyd] I came to Skid
Row back in the mid '80s.
- [Interviewer] Mid '80s?
- Mm hmm.
- [Interviewer] You were selling.
What drugs were you selling mostly?
- I used to sell cocaine.
I got turned on how to cook it.
I know how to cut it.
I know how to sell it.
Because I was from the country, you know?
I want to make some fast money,
that's what I did.
- [Interviewer] Figure it out.
- Yeah, figure it out, yeah.
Older people schooling me
telling me how to do it,
how to sell it and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] And what sells?
What sold more?
The powder or the rock?
- Well see, a lot of people
back then liked the rock.
They really liked both,
but when you're selling both
you don't get much time for the powder
and then do the rock.
You feel like the rock is
the drug of people of color
and the powder is for
the mostly rich people
that snort powder.
- [Interviewer] And your
customers would come from
other parts of the city
as well as Skid Row?
- Yeah, they used to come from Hollywood,
Santa Monica, you know all over basically.
All over, yes.
- [Interviewer] You were
the place to get it.
- Mm hmm, yes.
- [Interviewer] How
much money did you make
typically in a day?
- Well, mostly the night time
I would make about maybe
$1500 or $1600 or more.
- [Interviewer] At night?
- Yeah, at night.
- [Interviewer] That's good money.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Were there
other dealers that were like
"you're infringing on their territory?"
or vice versa?
- You know, we didn't really.
No, back then we didn't have that problem
because being downtown is neutral.
We don't have that problem.
If I go to someone else's hood
or other side of town
I might have some infliction;
but downtown is really neutral.
Downtown really neutral.
- [Interviewer] And the cops,
did you ever get thrown
in jail for carrying it?
- Yeah, I got thrown in jail.
My first time going to
jail out here was in '86,
then I got out because
it was simply possession.
But you know, back then
they really didn't trip on
cocaine like they do now
because they didn't really
know too much about it.
You know, another thing too
it wasn't having a big effect on people
like it do to this day
because they put a whole bunch of cut
and a whole bunch of
different chemicals in there.
Then you have some cocaine now it may be,
maybe I'm just exaggerating,
maybe 15 to 30 percent cocaine
the rest of it some garbage.
'Cuz it only take just
a little cocaine base
for you to go to jail
or prison for you know,
and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] How many
years were you in prison?
- [Floyd] Okay, I went to prison.
I went to prison.
I got out for doing 7 years and 8 months.
I got out January 1st, 2018.
I went for a conspiracy case
because they said that
I sold to an undercover,
which they didn't have no
marked money or no dope on me.
Only reason why they
convict me was my past.
They convict me from my past.
At first they said I sold to
an unidentified black male.
That was the story at first,
then they said I sold to an undercover.
They didn't cover no marked money
or no narcotic from me.
- [Interviewer] How much time did you do?
- [Floyd] Okay, they gave me 17 years.
With doing with good behavior,
rehabilitating myself in prison,
I got on about 57 which I
did 7 years and 8 months.
My release date was November 23rd, 2023
because I was 17 years and 80 percent,
you do 13 years and 4 months.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
Did you -
Were drugs apart of your
childhood in any way?
- [Floyd] You know, no.
No, drugs never was a
part of my childhood.
I really didn't know nothing about drugs
'til I came to California.
I was doing good in school.
I was a good athlete, you know, in school.
When I came out here I was a good athlete
but me being from the country
and making this type of
money was overwhelming.
"I like this, I like that." You know?
And stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] Did you
ever use it yourself?
- No, I never used.
No, I never used.
I never used no drugs
or anything like that.
Only drug I tried is weed
and last time I smoked
some weed was in '94.
- [Interviewer] All
right, you're not into it.
- No, I'm not into it.
No.
- [Interviewer] Can you
tell me about the lifestyle?
What hours would you keep
when you were selling?
- Well, when I was in school
I tried to hurry and finish
my basketball practice stuff
so I could come out and sell
till at least till about 10 o'clock
because I gotta be in the
house and go to school
the next morning.
- [Interviewer] 10? 10 AM?
- Nah, 10 at night.
I go to school right,
then I got to school I got practice
until about 4 and 5, maybe 6.
Then when I get,
I be trying to hurry up
and get through practice
so I can get out and make some money
before 10 o'clock at night
cause that's when my curfew was.
- [Interviewer] Oh I see.
- Yeah, that's what my curfew was.
- [Interviewer] Some of the guys
were selling through the night.
- Yes, through the night.
- [Interviewer] Did you ever do that?
- On weekends I did.
On weekends, yes.
- [Interviewer] So your
customers would just know
what corner you stood on
or where you hung out?
- Yes, you know, they did.
When you build your clientele up,
people gonna look for you.
People ain't gonna go to no where else
because they know they
ain't going to get beat,
they know they ain't going to get robbed,
they gonna get treated fairly.
When I used to sell,
I used to treat my customers fairly.
I used to treat them fairly.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, they
could always count on you.
- Yeah, they always could count on me.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] And, a
lot of addicts down here
on Skid Row so,
you had these people right
here in the neighborhood.
- Yeah, you know.
Since I been out, you know,
people still approach me
or ask me "Do you got
anything? Do you got anything?"
Nope. I'm working.
I got my life together.
I'm not doing that no more.
- [Interviewer] That's good for you.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You'll
stay out of jail that way.
- Yes, yes.
Yes sir.
- [Interviewer] So your wife passed away?
- Yes, so she passed away in
2010 while I was in prison.
- [Interviewer] Oh wow.
- Yeah, while I was in prison.
- [Interviewer] Any your kids?
- No we don't have no kids.
- [Interviewer] So you're on your own now?
- Yeah, I'm on my own now.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] So Floyd,
what's the craziest thing
you remember -
like when you were selling?
What kind of -
I'm sure you had stories
when you were out in
the streets doing this.
- Yeah, the craziest thing you see
that how females know the greatest stuff
about the product and stuff.
You know, they do
anything for that product
when they don't have no money.
You know, I look back at it now
and I really feel bad
to how I took advantage
of vulnerable people in that situation
when they feigning and stuff like that.
To be honest with you,
I asked the lord to forgive me
for all the people that I hurt
that I sold that stuff to.
On my conscious, it's clear.
I'm through that lifestyle.
I'm through with it.
It took me a while to
wake up and learn that
but I'm done with it.
And if people out there doing it,
there's more better ways
then life that hustle.
Show money, slow money,
is sure money.
You don't gotta worry about
living over your shoulder
when you got a 9 to 5.
(laughs)
You don't, you really don't.
You really don't.
- [Interviewer] Where do
you see yourself in 5 years?
- Well, I see myself in 5 years,
I'm going to intend to work
and I'd like to be a counselor.
I got certificates
and I feel to be a counselor
help people out
and don't make the same
mistakes I made in my past
because selling drugs is
not no future in that.
It took me a later age to realize that.
Now I woke up before it's too late.
I'm still blessed with my health
and doing stuff like that.
Five years I'd like to help people.
I'd like to be a counselor.
- [Interviewer] All right well,
thank you for talking to me.
- You welcome sir.
- [Interviewer] All right.
- All right then.
- [Interviewer] Be safe out there.
- Thank you sir.